[Music]
we've understood what density is in the
same given amount of space if there are
more things we say that it's denser
density is simply the measure of how
compact the mass in a substance or
object is its mass per unit volume and
based on this formula we can say that
it's unit is kilogram per meter cubed so
can you tell me what relative density is
look at the word relative what does it
tell you it tells us that we are looking
at the density of something relative to
the density of something we are
comparing the density of one thing to
the density of another that's all but
the question is relative to what it's
most typically the density of water yes
we look at the density of an object
relative to the density of water how do
we define the relative density of a
substance it equals the ratio of its
density to that of water
yes density of the substance over the
density of water can you tell me the
unit of relative density look at the
right hand side and tell me the unit as
it is a ratio of similar quantities
relative density will have no units the
units from the numerator and denominator
cancel each other out the density of
water is thousand kilograms per meter
cubed and the density of silver is
10,500 kilograms per meter cubed so can
you tell me the relative density of
silver it's easy just refer to this
formula and try answering it it will
equal the density of silver over the
density of water substituting the values
here we get the answer as 10.5 that's
the relative density of silver what does
the relative density tell us though what
can we understand from this first it
that silver is a lot more dense than
water under the given conditions
approximately ten point five times
denser but that's pretty obvious given
the numbers this tells us another
important thing it tells us whether the
object will float or sink in water in
simple terms a substance will sink if
it's denser than the liquid it's placed
in and it will float if it's less dense
than the liquid it's placed in how can
we say this mathematically if the
relative density of a substance is
greater than one then it will say and if
it's lesser than one it will float as
the relative density of silver is ten
point five which is greater than one it
will sink in water but if we take the
example of ice its density is
approximately nine hundred and
thirty-four kilograms per meter cubed so
it's relative density will be zero point
nine three four as its relative density
is lesser than one it will float in
water we can understand this with a
simple diagram take four beakers filled
with water in the first one drop a
substance with a relative density of 0.1
you'll see that it floats like this in
the second one drop a substance with
relative density of 0.4 and you'll see
that it floats like this more of it is
inside the water and if it's 0.9 even
more of it will be inside the water but
it will still float and if it's greater
than 1 say 1.2 or 1.3 then it will sink
ok here's one last question for you can
the relative density of an object be
zero the answer is no it can't be zero
because of the relative density is zero
it will mean that the density of the
substance is zero which in turn will
mean that the mass of the substance is
zero for any given substance its mass in
a given volume cannot be zero and you
should also know that relative density
is constant
only under given conditions it is
pressure and temperature dependent the
same substance can have different
relative densities under different
pressures or temperatures
[Music]
you